cette année les prairies ont bien donné
ici les 95 hectares de surfaces
agricoles servent uniquement à nourrir
le troupeau une alimentation bio pour
donner à lait bio le couple paulien a
choisi ce label depuis 2016 l'autonomie
est un réel atout
pour la traçabilité du produit que l'on
que l'on fait
ça rassure le consommateur et puis par
par économie où c'est on arrive à tirer
de meilleures marges en étant autonome
quand en achetant des à 32 l'extérieur
daniel folien vend l'essentiel de son
lait à la fromagerie migrer ses 60
vaches laitières produisent en moyenne
plus de lait que celle des exploitations
des environs en conventionnel la traite
est un des moments privilégiés de sa
journée
c'est là que l'on voit si on a bien
travailler ou pas si l'alimentation
était bonne pas s'il boit le rendement
qui a la qualité et pour bien nourrir
ses vaches daniel pauly a prend soin
tout particulièrement de ses sols depuis
20 ans bien avant de passer en bio il a
choisi d'appliquer les principes de
l'agriculture de conservation
fini les labours profonds on a fait des
comptages à deux tonnes et demie de vers
de terre hectares donc c'est une
activité biologique important
c'est ça qui fait la performance de du
sol
voilà il ya des curricula on laissait
flamand tout ça c'est des tueries que le
ver de terre donc c'est eux qui
participent au travail du sol
on n'a plus besoin d'interventions
mécanique ou très peu d'interventions
mécanique
daniel paulien a pu conserver cette
technique tout en passant en bio et
c'est une véritable prouesse le bio
c'est aussi ce qui a donné l'envié à son
épouse de quitter les champs pour créer
cet atelier
aurélie paulien transforme une petite
partie du lait de la ferme en yaourt ou
fromage blanc cette activité leur a
permis d'embaucher un salarié sur la
ferme la vente directe c'est très
prenant aujourd'hui mes enfants ils ont
plus besoin de moi donc c'est vrai que
je peux me permettre d'être à 100% sur
un atelier de transfo et je suis à plein
temps donc oui c'est du 65 70 heures par
semaine j'aime ce que je fais maintenant
j'ai une très bonne
une bonne valorisation du produit donc
c'est vrai que ça ne dérange pas de
travailler beaucoup
c'est dur mais mais je suis j'aime ça
j'aime ce que je fais
le couple ne sait pas encore si leur
fille reprendront à jour leur
exploitation c'est trop tôt plus
généralement ce qui les préoccupe c'est
l'avenir des exploitations agricoles en
haute saône pour dix départs en retraite
il y a seulement cette installation de
jeunes ce qui est inquiétant c'est que
[Musique]
sur 400 mille agriculteurs
actuellement la moitié vont prendre leur
retraite d'ici dix ans donc il va
falloir
renouveler la génération d'agriculteurs
il va falloir que de installe les jeunes
et aujourd'hui les jeunes sont de plus
en plus réticents pour s'installer en
agriculture moi j'aimerais que
qu'il y ait une meilleure image déjà
delà du métier d'agriculteur et que
les agriculteurs puissent être plus
épanouis dans leur métier mais donc par
là il passe le temps libre le pouvoir
pouvoir se reposer si aujourd'hui les
prix de vente de nos produits étaient
plus rémunérateurs on sentirait qui est
moi de malaise dans notre métier et les
gens les agriculteurs seraient plus
détendu
plus épanouie on a besoin de
de garantir notre souveraineté
alimentaire on a besoin d'un agriculteur
il faut absolument que la génération se
renouvelle si nous on va aller vers un
agrandissement d exploitation et je ne
suis pas sûr que c'est l'image que de
l'agriculture
que souhaite voir le consommateur voilà
c'est le moment de vous transmettre le
cahier de doléances et maintenant c'est
à vous d'écrire sur une nouvelle page de
ce cahier bon franchement si on veut
qu'ils aient des jeunes qui s'installent
dans l'agriculture il serait bon qu'ils
aient de meilleurs revenus
on aurait besoin aussi d'assurer notre
souveraineté alimentaire avec une
agriculture respectueuse de
l'environnement bio et performante